a  Houston police officer carried a mother  and her 13 month-old son through  floodwaters after rescuing them this  same spot is normally a busy eight-lane  highway before and after pictures like  these provide a startling look at the  catastrophic flooding and we don't use  that term lightly I mean look at that  that is nothing if not catastrophic  up the word catastrophic they really do  and startling after startling all the  images this morning right I mean elderly  people being rescued pulled out of water  one after another well that feels like  you know guys they're calling it the  worst flood disaster in US history and  those pictures certainly bear that out  you bet well roadways have disappeared  and water has reached treetops as you've  seen these photos of Houston show flood  water filling downtown streets this is a  look at Interstate 610 taken from a  traffic camera last year and this is  what it looked like after the historic  flooding in the area